así es
necesito
[Música]
y ahí sí
de amor
[Música]
era extremadamente
pero
nunca experimenté lo que si el muñeco
la actividad en esa ciudad
bueno
a los ocho años de edad dice yo
tienes instrumentos
me llamase para la música
s
y mandó a los otros años
inmediatamente
ahora
gracias
[Música]
ya está
personalmente solamente la voy a tocar
los derechos de unidad
ya muchas áreas de estudio
los otros cinco
su tiempo
fue una silla
con un guardia
y un par de atenas
la visión
una verdad
pasar una realidad
[Música]
y en el estado
entonces pasaban
y
el sábado
después de tiempo
humboldt
y ellos
la edad
as
es un
sí
empiezo a tocar con grupos
como profesionista no tenía
[Música]
así
cucharas
ah
[Música]
la ciudad
tres meses basura
y
un poco de anillos había
no
ah
incluso
había mejorado el rendimiento que hay
nos ayudará
también
y ahí es donde me intereso por dar gusto
no diga nada
el uso del mismo del habla es el uso de
la música de manera sistemática
y especializada en la música
sincronizada porque nos reímos internas
con ritmos hacemos
una vida
vamos
sin hogar
y así
de todas las mujeres
verdad algunos
nos ayuda a decir
lo que no que sí
tristes
vamos
[Música]
y nada más
el tenemos una experiencia vuelta
música
[Música]
así es
y había
ah
[Música]
llega semana
llegó sin igual
ah
y le digo excitación
[Música]
ah
y
[Música]
ah
no no
no
sí
[Música]
es no
me dice
desde un mundo
pero aprendí de la ciudad
es decir
y entonces nuevo
o sea
de manera de estimular hacia el logro
[Música]
creando una proyección
es
hacia el 1 1
[Música]
qué es
y lenguaje
[Música]
regular es por ejemplo
i
nuestra atención
si tenemos un problema
[Música]
y obviamente la atención hacia el tema
hacer
y
[Música]
y eso de nada
la redonda le hicimos a través de
ejercicios de estimulación estimulada
y lograr lo que es
por ejemplo si estuviéramos en una lista
desierta
una vez
lleva todos los amores completos
como para nada más
cada despacito
cuándo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
qué es
gracias
ahora
será
y 12
antes
está mal
y
y además desde atrás
[Música]
no no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de amor
sí
de esa cualidad
ahora
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
existen
un aspecto activo se usa los
instrumentos del cuerpo
[Música]
sí
ahora
para que la frecuencia tiene
directamente irregular de un muscular
estos niños
quizás las panteras movimientos
d
louis
ródenas bien
la depresión
él
no es así
ahora
la presencia
mínimos
pero tienes
estamos en una clase
a decir
[Música]
entonces el niño que estábamos
en el mundo 2
los
más
pero no
sus números
lluvias
de sus armas
y
la llegada es esto
[Música]
sra
en el mismo
[Música]
hay comunidad de regresar
en el mundo
d
nos engañan
dios
[Música]
entonces
y sí mismo
tiene ingresar a los huevos
en el punto que sea más difícil
es algo así
la verónica
[Música]
y ahí
ya es
no más
ah
y
sí
entonces
y él
y para que seamos una
[Música]
sí
y más
lo que nos decimos nada
el último
hola
[Música]
igual